hi i'm elon musk wait what
no i'm not i'm john coogan man that
artificial intelligence stuff is really
getting out of hand
but we'll get to that anyway today we're
running through every elon musk
controversy
and discussing what's legitimate what's
unfounded and how you should think about
controversies if you're an entrepreneur
elon musk recently became the richest
person on earth with over 186 billion
dollars to his name
he's a super controversial guy so i
thought it'd be interesting to run
through some of the biggest
controversies he's faced in his career
and give my thoughts
the first elon controversy starts before
he was even born
it's the claim that his father owned an
emerald mine in zambia
and it's often used by his detractors to
paint him as someone who had everything
handed to him
and didn't really have to work to become
successful there are two key points here
first is the claim true and second does
that diminish his success
on the first point the evidence is a bit
mixed it does look like his father owned
a 50
stake in an emerald mine for a time but
that the mine eventually went
bust and there isn't any evidence that
his father was a mining tycoon or
anything close to it
he was an engineer but it does appear
that musk grew up fairly wealthy by
south african standards
it's clear that elon had plenty of books
to read and the opportunity to buy a
computer at a young age
when they were still widely inaccessible
to the general public
his family owned one of the biggest
houses in pretoria and he was able to
attend a private school
so even though the emerald mine story
might get a bit exaggerated by people
trying to bring him down
elon was fortunate enough to come from a
financially secure background
interestingly while nearly everyone who
cites the emerald mind story now
hates elon and is doing it to bring him
down the story was originally posted by
a huge
fan of elon musk who just thought it was
an interesting tidbit of history
so if elon did come from money should
that change your perception of him
i don't really think so because the vast
majority of his wealth was created
through businesses he started and grew
himself there are plenty of rich kids
who just coast through life
and never really take the time to try
and learn hard science or have an impact
on the world at
all so if you are fortunate enough to
have a wealthy family
just know that expectations are only
going to be higher for you you can't
change where you're from
so the only option is to put your head
down and build the second major
controversy in elon's career came
shortly after he sold his first company
zip2 to compaq for 307 million dollars
a physicist named john o'reilly filed a
lawsuit alleging that elon had stolen
his idea for the company
while it's true that elon had met
o'reilly before
founding zip2 it looks like o'reilly
never really pursued the idea
and was mostly looking for a piece of
elon's windfall in fact
o'reilly's company had already been
dissolved by the time he brought the
lawsuit
and the judge ultimately dismissed the
case and ordered o'reilly to pay elon
125 000 in legal fees elon never made
him pay though
so what's the takeaway for entrepreneurs
well if you get sued after selling your
company
it probably will be a headache but
you'll definitely have the money to
defend yourself
but what about people stealing your idea
in my experience
any good startup idea will be copied
iterated on and mutated
as soon as it starts getting traction
that's part of competition in the
capitalist system
and if you're an entrepreneur you should
be ready for that
you will always have competitors so your
job is to build a stronger company that
delivers a better product to its
customers
the third controversy actually came
directly out of that lawsuit
while o'reilly was digging into elon
before bringing him to court
he found that elon's degrees from the
university of pennsylvania
were granted in 1997 two years later
than elon had been stating publicly
in his biography of elon ashley vance
dug into this academic record
and found that everything actually
checked out it turned out that elon was
just missing two credits to graduate on
time
and he was planning on doing them at
stanford but after upenn
changed their graduation requirements
and elon decided not to do a phd at
stanford at all
upend let him graduate oddities in
academic records like this are
dime-a-dozen in silicon valley
dropping out is extremely trendy and
people often take gap years to work on
startups the important lesson to take
away from this is that you need to be
honest about what you've actually done
no one in the technology industry cares
if you're missing a random history
credit
but if you lie about it that will erode
trust and hurt your credibility
after elon sold zip2 he started a new
venture called
x.com in the online payment space x.com
eventually merged with confinity to
become
paypal while nearly everyone
acknowledges elon as a co-founder of
paypal now
that wasn't always the case startup
mergers can be very messy
and at the early stages it's often
unclear who's doing what
add to that the fact that elon was
ousted as ceo
after only a few months in the role and
you can see why people were unclear
about whether or not he really was a
co-founder
this all blew up in the press when
sequoia capital one of the early backers
of paypal
pulled elon's picture from their website
this could have just been them rotating
pictures
but the tech industry gossip blogs
jumped on it nevertheless
elon responded by writing a lengthy open
letter explaining exactly what he had
contributed to paypal while he was there
the most powerful part of elon's
argument to me is the fact that he was
the largest shareholder when the company
went public
typically if there's a co-founder
dispute early on and someone leaves
they won't vest their shares or they'll
be deluded
so the fact that he held on to so much
of the company makes me believe that his
contribution was real co-founder titles
can mean different things at different
startups
sometimes there's a technical person
with a co-founder title who doesn't
really oversee the business or sit on
the board
other times there's a co-founder who
serves only as the chairman of the board
and doesn't really have a day-to-day
role at all it's important to clarify
these things early on when the company
is formed
since people can have a very emotional
connection to their co-founder title
oh and sequoia capital the vc firm who
took
elon off of their website they just gave
elon 500 million dollars during spacex
latest funding round
so i doubt there are any hurt feelings
today
speaking of spacex our fourth
controversy comes from a 60 minutes
interview where elon had
what some thought of as an overly
emotional response to criticism
from some nasa astronauts here's the
clip
but spacex's lack of experience bothers
some nasa legends
like apollo astronauts neil armstrong
and gene cernan
they've testified to congress that the
obama administration's drive to
commercialize space
could compromise safety and eventually
cost the taxpayers
now is the time to overrule this
administration's
pledge to mediocrity you know there are
american heroes
who don't like this idea neil armstrong
gene
cernan have both testified against
commercial space flight and the way that
you're developing it
and i wonder what you think of that
i was very sad to see that because those
guys are
yeah you know those guys are heroes of
mine so it's really tough
you know i i wish they would come and
visit and and see the hardware they were
doing camp
and i think that would change their
minds they inspired you to do this
didn't they
yes and to see them casting stones in
your direction
it's difficult i think it's fine to be
passionate about what you're working on
and this clearly shows that elon really
cares about advancing space travel
to be fair to the astronauts who
testified against spacex
this was back in 2012 and there was
still a lot of uncertainty about whether
or not spacex's approach of cheaper
reusable rockets would ever work
but looking back on it now they look
ridiculous spacex just delivered nasa
astronauts
to the international space station and
they did it flawlessly
elon has a unique ability to think in
decades and undertake wildly ambitious
projects
this is certainly true of spacex and
it's also true at tesla
but that has also led to many many
controversies
elon has a long history of publicly
announcing a launch date for a new tesla
model
and then missing that deadline this is
because he tends to think of timelines
as the true
minimum amount of time it would take to
do something if everything goes
perfectly
early in his career the engineers he was
working with at zip2
had a mental model for dealing with
elon's ambitious timelines
they said we came to interpret an hour
as really taking a day or two
and if elon ever did say something would
take a day
we allowed for a week or two weeks it's
good to be ambitious about timelines
when you're running a startup
since you're likely not profitable every
extra day
burns more of your cash and pushes you
closer to running out of money
but it's important to have a fundamental
reason for why
a deadline is where it is and believe
that it's actually possible to hit it
here's how elon describes it one thing i
should say like
the like when i when i sort of cite a
schedule it is actually the schedule
i think is true it's it's not some fake
schedule that i don't think is true
um maybe delusional that is entirely
you know possible maybe it's happened
from time to time
but it's it's it's never um
you know some knowingly fake deadline
ever
setting impossible deadlines will
demotivate employees
so it's important to at least have a
shot at hitting your goal
even if you know that something might
inevitably come up and delay the project
the last controversy i want to cover
involves elon's take on artificial
intelligence
unlike most silicon valley techno
optimists
elon is terrified of ai taking over
here's how he summarized his position in
2018
i'm really quite close to very close to
the cutting edge in ai and it scares the
hell out of me
um it's capable of vastly more than
almost anyone knows
and the rate of improvement is
exponential
you can see this in things like alphago
which went from
in the span of maybe six to nine months
it went from being unable to beat even a
reasonably good go player
to then beating the european world
champion who was ranked 600
then beating lisa doll four five um
who had been world champion for many
years then beating the current world
champion then beating everyone
while playing simultaneously then uh
then there was alpha zero
uh which crushed alpha go 100 to zero
and alpha zero just learnt by playing
itself
and it can play basically any game that
you put the rules in for
if you whatever rules you give it
literally read the rules play the game
and be superhuman
for any game um nobody expected that
rate of improvement if you ask those so
those same experts uh who think ai
is not progressing at the rate that i'm
saying i think you'll find that their
predictions
for things like go and and other and
other uh ai advancements have
uh the batting average is quite weak
it's not good
after elon started talking publicly
about the potential dangers of ai
there was a fair amount of backlash from
the ai industry
what i find so interesting about elon's
position is that it's very rare to see
techno pessimism
coming from within the tech industry
itself typically the loudest voices that
are critical of new technology
come from journalists academics and
executives at
industries that stand to benefit from
that technology stagnating
elon is often criticized for being
overly optimistic
and spreading a tech will save the world
message every chance he gets
but his position on ai really shows you
that he considers each technology on its
own merits
and i like that there are honestly a ton
more controversies involving elon
but i don't want this video to run too
long so i'll have to do a follow-up
if you like this video please consider
subscribing to the channel
if you have any thoughts on elon musk
just leave a comment below
thanks for watching